hello and welcome to the Friday review
of games I is always in Dan Galpin and
with me is its kokhim back for impacts
oh absolutely we had a great time last
week and over to our right in the Lewis
and Todd Kerpelman which you'll notice
picture start hey hey there everybody
I'm producer Ian can you hear me okay
can you hear me yeah alright we've got
new microphones today so if you love the
audio quality let me know if you don't
love it then I'm out about 800 bucks
that's gonna suck alright so the beach
today is actually left over from last
saturday's team BBQ it is and that's why
the the label looks so screwed up
because it actually sat in a tub of what
used to be ice all week it's been a it's
kind of its kind of triple foundation
going on Nichevo nope what really killed
me those i I didn't expect any of the
beer to be there I mean it was it was
basically out on my front porch where
any hobo could grab it and yeah camo
boat in and I'll tell you why I think
it's because most of the homeless people
around my house only come through the
back because that's where all the
recyclables are so anyway we've got got
lucky this time this is from the single
hop series from Hermitage it's Hermitage
right yes yes what they do is they brew
an IPA every month or two that has just
one hop and today it's autonome hops or
atina or AHA to them and by weight you
may have noticed a newcomer to my left
is in turn Todd so uh I just in the
hallway and they grabbed me yeah yeah I
know what I'm doing here oh that's too
young to drink but he'll be getting us
coffee later
different odd you should have said
something if you wanted me to bring a
glass it's a you know I'll finish this
water and then I will take some of that
beer I'm a delicious girl huh excellent
yes ain't lettin ya feds are gonna grab
us alright so back to Dan and co for a
some drinky time and some gay mika so
what are we what are we going to talk
about this weekend well we're talking
about actually card games in general and
specifically in in collectible card
games these are trading card games we
actually have four examples of that of
those in our set today we also have one
which is just a fun card puzzle game
that we've added as well and and these
games are Chris are wildly wildly
popular all right we'll play oh and by
the way for all of you who are
interested I am actually wearing a
garlic at this is probably not the best
view of sad happy I'm sure we'll switch
to the other camera at some point in the
show yes seriously garlic though no it
it is really yeah I know really just
this is this I this was this was
retrieved from gilroy gardens which is
really beautiful down in Gilroy I know
that beautiful when Gilroy and Gardens
might not be something that actually
dives for many of you who haven't been
down there but they did a beautiful
beautiful job in the theme park and so
yes to celebrate I have this foam hat so
so we're so it's talked about the first
game and this this game is kind of
important because it has been for a
while the number one top grossing game
on Google Play yeah that's pretty
incredible anything about it and yes so
i guess like first up we're gonna be
talking about rage of bahamut this one
collectible card game from our friends
out from japan it's published by DNA but
developed by saima agent and so we're
just loading up the game right here
right now
dark summoner oh man he's not as a
wholesome with the whole show not that
way sauce though that's good let's wait
is it not fair oh wait that's not good
I'll tell you what just put up that all
right excellent excellent so by the way
uh rato is filling in for Dan fam so
thanks rato so the Dan could actually
eat something soon o mighty net to
choose your wood it's unintentional
comedy we love that on the show so let's
talk about rage of Bahamut now a rage of
Bahamut is game that i looked at and i
was that would honestly when i first
looked at it um let's tell you what it
looks like on my friends in asia talk
about it they're just like oh you should
play you should play it I'm like sure
okay eventually so why not this week was
week's check it out absolutely so let's
take a look at rage of Bahamut so there
we are now this is running on a
transformer prime and one of the things
you'll notice immediately is it this
game was not in any way designed to run
on a transformer prime you'll see are
any other tablet it looks about the same
on my Nexus 7 as well exactly and so you
know what what we're what we're seeing
here is the game is actually a giant web
view um it actually uses web views and
flash and in various parts of the game
it and it's actually and this this has
some interesting side effects in the
game so you can tap to start a battle
once again you can see the interface is
uh incredibly much like using a website
yep so we can go ahead and go start up a
battle or request mm-hmm
and but now I'm like being taken to
another tutorial that's good I was going
to say so it loads so how's the
experience of this game is actually like
playing a web page in a lot of ways and
that does not actually detract from the
game itself the game is about greed and
and about collecting really awesome
cards with really beautiful artwork and
but it's really not in any way an
android game it's it's really it's
really a combination of a bunch of
technology sort of thrown together to
produce the desired monetization results
and and which is which is cool you can
see here on the tab and I will and in
full and full full disclosure the game
actually boots up and says sorry we've
never tested on this device good luck
all right when you actually try to run
it on this so so props to them for for
recognizing that it's probably not going
to be the best experience here but again
see we're actually getting to a quest
quest yeah it's taking me a while sorry
that's okay I'm glad you're running at
this time right I've been I'm sort of
trying not to look at it the whole time
so because it actually is running as a
webview there are actually some
interesting side effects one is that so
there we are this actually is actually
the game you see does go fullscreen
rather nicely you're you know the
pixelization you're saying is is very
real all right these are we're it like
basically what I would describe as g1
quality graphics here but what and I
think that's mostly because the game is
loaded up artwork that it's thinking
that it's looking at the the density of
the screen only and so if you're if
you're you know on a tablet like this if
you're going to go to full screen and
you're going to be using you know mdpi
our assets you know it's just not going
to look good because you know those
assets are designed based upon pixel
density and they would be really tiny on
the screen so better actually they're
scaled up like this then leaving them
really really small but you know we done
it does he do end up with this
kind of weird look where you have this
really beautiful artwork as you can see
a car I'm sure on the menu at the top so
you can't even see what the name and ID
card is june from swat something is our
man yeah so at which would be nice again
to do it isn't it hasn't been tested on
tablets clearly you know i wish they had
done a little bit more more work on that
there you can also see that you know the
game is a little bit cut off at the
bottom of the screen as well it looks
like it's having issues with this aspect
ratio which again is kind of interesting
because it's it's kind of its web view
based there is actually sound in the
game it does have stirring music plays
behind the game yes and it actually does
handle the sound correctly as i recall
from from my basic test this game and
actually does you know when you lock the
phone when you lock the phone or a
tablet and unlock it it actually does
play this on correctly now what I think
is interesting here you notice we're in
the middle of the game and you might
you'll say at the bottom of the screen
or mean may not be able to quite see on
this that there actually are is the zoom
and compatibility controls on there and
if we actually hit the back key from
within the game I'm here actually it
actually goes back in the web do that so
we can actually we keep going back and
we can go back into our last battle we
play the battle again yeah so you know
it's just kind of entertaining I guess I
think this is sort of on a 10-inch
unintended consequences but it is kind
of surprising that to be this lack of
level of lack of detail all right to be
honest in the game it seems like you
know and of course it doesn't doesn't
navigate in the way we would expect an
Android application to navigate because
of that as well you know and of course
it doesn't actually do anything when you
replay it by the way they thought this
this is a server based game so it's
really just replaying the client side
pieces of that last battle so you know
they're there you go so yeah so in terms
of layout definitely as a motive I mean
even if you look at here if you can't
the bottom part you have to kind of
scroll up in order to see the full thing
but then the menu taskbar blocks the
bottom yeah
kind of a mess you know I know I I think
what I know now I think now that they
recognize that you know people are
excited about the concept of the game in
really that that's what makes the game
fun there's there's a lot of their
social interaction there's a lot of
trading of really exciting artwork in
cards the game is actually strategic the
further you get into it the more there
is um it's massively multiplayer all I
have a certain orders you like you know
you team up with other people i mean you
play against other people i mean and
then you can there's also this really
cool card evolution mechanic that i see
in a lot of japanese collectible card
galleys that's really cool too so it
also keeps you engaged as even in a
single player mode versus like even a
multiplayer mode and because it's
basically a web game this allows them to
run all sorts of really interesting
events and that's really what drives a
lot of the of the plot of people going
back and playing the game it drives a
lot of the engagement so what I was
looking for um in the game is that is it
you're constantly every single week
they're running something new there's
some other reason for you to go and
check in on the game so this you know
one of this one of the things that this
actually says is that sometimes working
out the mechanics of the game is
actually more important than the
elements in the game right on the other
hand I would think that if they actually
could combine these things they would
have a game that was even more
successful you know right now there's a
lot of one star reviews in the game
we're just like this game looks like ass
we're glad to say that on the show I'm
not sure anyways you know but yeah and
and and and I would love to see this
game look and play and be as and the
other thing about is the interface is
confusing great and I think that you
know what I really want to see is an ear
face that actually doesn't potentially
deter a new player and a lot of one ends
up happening with this game is they
really have to walk through the game
pretty deeply in order to get it because
it is very cluttered and it is very kind
of if it is very hard to look at so well
for a lot of reasons you know you know
if we were looking at a game that we
thought was exciting that did a lot of
cool stuff when Android this would not
be it but it is exciting in terms of the
fact that they've created this dynamic
community around the game you know dan &
Co
I just want to mention that during the
time that you spent criticizing this
game it appears to have pulled in more
money than in turn Todd is expected to
make over its lifetime yeah exactly so
when I would at eighty dollars oh man I
just I mean it kind of just shows you
how like how much potential there is in
this collectible card segment I mean
like if this is a game that can pull in
a lot of revenue and there's still a lot
to be said about like you know making it
I mean consider how much more
improvement to convey just by changing
to you I hire as assets I mean and then
just fixing some of the weird like
control issues I mean you're just gonna
be converting a lot more players in the
paying a lot of stuff I mean whoever is
paying for this money must be a very
dedicated players I have no idea but I
will say this if I could make in a year
what these guys make in a day I would be
very satisfied I think most people would
say then yeah sure why do you guys are
making but but you know I you know when
it comes down to is that is that um
scada attacks name ahem game mechanics
are important and and and so in this
this game demonstrates that if you have
the right game mechanics you can
actually kind of slack off on other
parts of the game that being said i
would love lakoff it's a great start but
what I would love to see is I would love
to see this game actually go to a full
beautiful polished experience you know
all around and I nodded I feel if
they're if they're if they're issues as
much as hitting the back key doesn't not
only not do the right thing but it
actually goes and replays the last thing
you did right no it just makes me think
did anyone ever actually try pressing
that in QA well you know we see these
things sometimes right these are the
Blair Witch Project games yeah right all
right but um but again you know props to
all to them for creating a game that
monetizes really well and I think that
you know this is that they're going to
take these learning so they're gonna put
them into games that are more that are
more and more evolved in terms of design
and I think I think that's cool and it's
important to talk about this because
again you know the reason the reason
it's more talk about this is the most
important is the most popular you know
in one of the best
monetizing things on google play that
being said you know I don't want
everyone to go out and run it out and
say they're gonna make collectible card
games first of all right it really is
not easy to designer no it's I like to
put card games are probably some of the
hardest game design like texting I mean
like in together right hardest to get
right I mean all the balancing the
different types of like classes have to
make all the gameplay at this and it's
very hard to do is this and there is an
enormous amount of artwork in this game
right not let me do not let me deal out
my comments about the general look and
feel and interface this game underscore
the massive amount of work that went
into this game right it is simply it is
simply unfortunate that it seems like
the last twenty percent of the work
could have made the game ten times
better for as experience hey you know I
just want to break in one more time
because I Tom you on the YouTube stream
has just mentioned that he's a long time
washer TV viewer and he's got a game
called paddle tronic duel he's been
watching our show for months and has
incorporated everything we told him to
mm-hmm and his his game is now pulling a
4.6 rating hey awesome saying why yeah I
think I'm thanks for watching yeah let's
put it in the hopper let's take a look
at it later good take I make a note that
electronic duo chronic damn alright so
let's go on to the next game I want to
ask you guys more question about so you
say this is primarily you know using
webview to display just about everything
yes does that mean that when I'm done
playing on my tablet or on my phone I
could go to my computer you know start
up chrome and somehow play this online
you guys yes you can I will say there is
one weirdness about this game and
actually want to mention it they do
something which is very bad for the
ecosystem in this game and and that is
what they actually do is they read the
identity of the device and they tie the
ability to get certain presence present
within the game not presents and being
here uh within the game in to that
specific piece of hardware so they read
the hardware ID once that hardware ID
has been registered with an account
can never be registered with another
account against kind of sad me on this
kind of thing that makes android carrier
partners with very very mad because what
ends up happening is someone goes into
the ATT store gets a refurbished device
comes back out with a device tries to
hook up rage and they can't get any
presents on their device because someone
else had already pre owned the device so
please please please don't do this I
think that I think that it's one of
those things that we're starting to like
less and less because we realized it has
a really negative impact on the
ecosystem and this but this was the most
blatant I've ever seen in this cane
there is you have to verify your device
ID and it locks your device ID to your
account permanently yeah so so really
really I don't know what to say but but
whatever you do do not not do this I
don't care what reason you think you
might have for doing this i know the
reason why a lot of people try to do
this is they sometimes ty presence to to
to registering a new account from a
different device but don't do that this
is this is the one place in which in the
model in which you're going to damage
the ecosystem more than you are actually
going to help your game and things that
damage the ecosystem make the guys at
Google Play really upset and they're
less likely to promote the game they're
less likely to want to talk to you
they're more likely to you know again
it's just it's just it's just common
sense but also is it doesn't make much
sense to really tie hardware into a game
like that's not what it's about it's
about making sure that you can recognize
and that user comes back and so so
that's about it there I just wanted to
mention that because it was particularly
egregious right again I'd love to see
them actually target SDK the newer SDK
version although in truth in this game
if you zoom to fill screen it actually
does look a little bit better I've
switched it to zoom it does give you
notice crash but you know the game is so
low res to begin with as it turns out
zooming to phils green actually might be
the way to play the game so you know if
you're going to put this little effort
into your tablet to you have it leaving
that in there might not be the worst
idea in the world
so you here you will see the zoomed
version of the game actually this is
what the game you know probably should
look like so tragically enough this is
this is one of those rare cases in which
actually leaving the Zoom button in
probably a good idea just because the
game is so weak at actually rendering at
the real screen resolution that's this
is I mean this game is kind of why the
Zoom button exists at all right it's
because you know we you know we wanted
to make sure that even if the game
developer put zero work into trying to
make things work on on a tablet device
that that users could still take
advantage of this you know old kind of
creddie content on their tablets and and
you know that's unfortunately like
there's a lot of stuff that's really
high res in the game that is now lost so
but overall I think experience actually
is better than good mm-hmm so all right
guys let me just break in for just a
second yeah first remind you that you're
rambling again dan I thought we talked
about this I guess I sugar vine most of
you be going to meetings Todd your buddy
you remember that yeah yeah okay all
right second um we just had some of your
comments and mentioning there is not a
theme on moderator page for next week
and co I remember we we talked about
this and you want to go a slightly
different direction you want to talk
about that really quickly so our viewers
know what's going on sure we can pull
the rage of bahamut logo off of the
screen yes whoo now that we're talking
about well I think it's like cuz we're
late oh wait we decided to introduce
theme so that people can so we can
highlight different genres and all this
stuff but it seems like some of our
viewers think it's better to just kind
of highlight the best highlight each new
games coming in this week so we thought
would maybe maybe worth a shot to be
like hey every week why don't you guys
nominate the games we should be looking
at and we will refresh that every wait
week but we'll take we'll take a look at
the top five or six that ends up being
go to the top and that will be our show
so I don't know if you guys want to try
that out you think tin yeah that's how
was a sense the thought we had actually
was kind of combining these but I think
for next week we are gonna go for a nun
themed week again
to go back to our old store our old
school style also Co will not be here
sadly its head safer guess she'll be off
in Asia for two games oh no it's
actually Korea first korea japan tokyo
game show so she's on a whirlwind trip
but in any case yeah so next week we're
gonna go without a theme people just you
know were one more week you nominate
whatever you think is cool we'll go
through the list will pick the top games
or some of the top things I'm going to
based upon what we've looked at before
and then we'll probably go back to
theming the week after but will always
try to save some slots to look at some
of what's new because that is some
feedback we've gotten is it hey there's
new stuff and if I have to wait six
weeks before i get to a theme that
hatches my day that's not very very
helpful of what i really wanted to get
the ability to get some visibility
through the show so i think it makes a
lot of sense we're gonna try a
compromise there alright let's go on to
the next game next game would be dry
land which is another collectible card
get battle game from our folks i agree
and so very very similar to what you've
probably seen in the from the DNA folks
in rage of bahamut looks like it is
another web view game um look slightly
less obtrusive many bars this time
around yeah so the design the design is
actually kind of a combination of both
better and worse on a tablet the better
news is it really does fill the screen
which is really great the bad news is
actually the buttons are really really
sad yes and if you notice every time I
load the screen it loads up some really
weird white background with agree leg
things so go back into questing yeah I'm
not sure it just it feels like there's a
little polish waiting missing there too
i'm not i'm not sure why that does that
so this club cardium is actually really
really popular in japan and so they
ended up bringing it to the US and like
a lot of it is is just i mean the point
is you have all these hunter cards and
these hundred cards or what you would
probably get from either questing or
from going as other players or you know
participating and special events I mean
just like it
than any other collectible card game
sometimes they'll get normal cards
sometimes we get the super rare cards
and so here I am you know I kind of
lucked out i got two rare cards in my
first 5-10 minutes of playing the game i
must be really lucky i I think they
actually like giving you some rare cards
early on to greater to to get you kind
of you know sort of like all right all
right this is cool I want a 4900 to
attack power when normal cards are only
2500 yes going through the game a lot
faster so does all right let's play some
ghost poon system quest here in the game
once again you know this is sort of a
web style game yeah i just hit an event
oh no i don't know if i want to play
this dude he cutting he kind of
destroyed me last time really battered
battle dire I want to battle dire
monster well sure sure why not we can be
demonstrating what happens when we lose
right I didn't you know who knows we
might witness see and so this is like
another weird thing I mean obviously
this doesn't take full it is obviously
not a tablet-optimized me it only takes
up ah the tiny anymore tiniest part on
the tougher third part of this game so
that's not fun I looks like I did win
and hey yeah you know again um uh I'm
we're glad that the game works I mean
this game actually does does actually
have the screen code in it correctly so
we can't zoom it in right um so you know
again it's it's it's it's kind of sad
like to see like to see the guy that red
curry actually work a little bit on
getting this to run better on on android
tablet but it does run at least yes it
does run which is good and the art style
is really nice I think it's really cute
that they took a super deformed version
characters for all the hunters and like
I mean you do pick up a lot of stuff up
they have some really interesting
elements same thing evolving cards um
just enhancing cards pretty similar
mechanic so I think that although that's
like really nice and all the event
structure is really nice too but I mean
just like the rage of bahamut game if
you press the back button
you will go back to something you'd
previously done previously done hey look
I got another quest card again no it's
actually the same exact event that I did
last time anyway good going back to ya
guys is that because the back button is
actually acting like a web server but
you're going straight into the rack it's
going straight into the web view and so
and so I know again this is no no
attempt has been made to actually handle
it and so this is the default behavior
is it it moves through the web page and
it shows you actually just how much of
the game is written as a web page now
you know one of the reasons is that
they're there isn't a lot of advantages
of doing this one of them is it not
every platform allows you to iterate as
quickly as Android does go to the store
and so you know if you're if you're
trying to do create a really interactive
game that has lots and lots of events on
some other platforms this might be the
only way to do it but on Android you
really can actually you know the ability
to update the game constantly with the
ability to run interpreters in your game
you really can actually avoid this
create something that's very tuned to
the platform as well and you know as
well as I as very very you know timely
and so i think i'd like to see someone
actually go through and say hey in with
the ability to iterate rapidly on google
play with the ability to run interpreted
code let's take android and really take
it to the next level and make the next
really awesome awesome game like this
something that is just a beautiful
android experience right I i think it is
actually in our contract as Google
engineers we're not allowed to actually
criticize html5 but we might suggest
that HTML isn't the best way to write a
game on android you're putting a lot of
other things between you and the system
and some of those behaviors make sense
but some of them don't yeah and I think
a lot of it also is that you know this
game does not make heavy use of any of
the rich HTML features html5 features in
terms of like they could make this game
work offline they could make the game
you know right now you if you're not if
you do not have an active internet
connection it is not a pretty sight if
you try to play this game you know so
there's there's a lot of things that
just fall out of the fact that it's not
just it's not just a question of using
webview it's sort of a very minimalist
use of html5
there's all people doing amazing stuff
with html5 um this is not the game that
is doing that yeah and I think like one
other thing is unlike rage of bahamut it
actually has audio I mean maybe I was
only playing is on the one by says it
but I'm playing this of a play this game
on my galaxy nexus there is no audio and
most collectible card battle games
usually has some sort of epic background
audio music album playing back because I
know it is your you are fighting
monsters absolutely there should be some
audio so don't probably be another I
mean you can't tell from the showcase
because obviously we don't have audio
playing but it's probably one thing I
would like maybe well you know it does
it does prevent them from getting audio
wrong though rectly gets I'll give them
that so you know they're there aren't
there are 0 audio problems we were able
to text with this game so
congratulations degree for making sure
they didn't violate any of our audio
audio kind of declamatory issues that we
usually have um that's right let's it
senses I think we've seen as much as
what about we're gonna see if this gains
so let's go let's go on to the next
that's Japanese collectible card battle
game exactly you know as a theme here uh
now this game is interesting they use a
lot ooh hold on I've just I've just
jiggled there we are no yeah well they
have some epic intro video here which I
thought was pretty cool they used a
actually this game actually uses a lot
of video and it within the game which is
actually pretty cool and and it does it
does make the game feel like it is
richer it also does a much better job of
filling the screen yeah and actually
having a tablet friendly you I so props
to them on that it feels so old-school
from a UI perspective it's really funny
but so I am so so basically you know
from from a from a general you I
perspective this is a lot closer like I
really do think that that there were
almost there it's still it still is
using old school in terms of the API
level that they're targeting it still
has the kazoom kind of unnecessary
button you know it one thing with web
views that's interesting is there it is
there are some challenges with
using accelerated web views on ICS
devices so you know there is some extra
testing that needs to go in there I
would say we didn't get everything right
in terms of getting accelerated 2d
working really really well with web
views on ICS but that being said this
game would really really be helped by
having it so I think it's you know I
think it'd be worth their while to
actually target the latest versions of
Android and use and use acceleration
hardware acceleration I think that you
know what game would be a lot smoother
maybe actually be kind of curious to say
I haven't tried this just just forcing
it and seeing what happens what did you
want you I don't wanna go it's going to
go for broke this is this is being able
I guess for you we're gonna do this live
yeah alright so so so let's just see
what happens we'll pull down it's either
gonna die or it's going to be totally
awesome so once again one thing it says
kind of fun that you can do in the
developer options is you can actually do
a couple things we can show touches but
one thing's we can also do is force GPU
rendering so a nap so this will now
cause a lot of applications to crash but
will cost some of them to actually run
faster so we'll see what David see all
right does it crash crash not yet well
the video seems to run video is playing
that's a good sign but we'll see what
happens they said this is a it's
something that's very easy to do in your
own games you can actually even have
your QA Department or have a producer go
in and turn this you know flip this
switch on and just see whether it
crashes or not you'll get it you'll get
an idea you know really really early on
whether or not you know your there's
gonna be some engineering work the bonus
details not yet discovered a second
let's go back into that's into the
actual game itself but yeah you see that
how much more how much more smoothly
this is scrolling now like this is an
entirely better experience and all they
would have had to do is target the
recent SDK version to get this so yeah I
think they should definitely do this now
whether or not we're actually gonna run
into a bug somewhere because of it I
don't know the other thing this is fun
is you can actually do do a do a summon
and it actually produces this kind of
cool this kind of cool graphic just to
show you the fact that they've actually
integrated you know full motion video
into the game in all sorts of places
and so it is kind of fun it adds
something new also again you get some
beautiful artwork here I mean just you
know really really well done so and and
you'll see that actually this this is
something I've always suggested on the
show is it when you actually have text
at full resolution you actually can have
fairly low resolution graphics and still
have them look great what looks awesome
here is the picture and the green soul
Banshee and the attack and defense and
health all the information about this
card it's actually when you see when
they get into this pretty text here is
when things really start to look bad the
new summon complete these aliens soul
points here at the bottom so you know
once again you know I would say that you
get a lot by actually using our built-in
fonts and built in text or just our
built-in font rendering in terms of
keeping compatibility across a lot of
devices and as you can see no we
actually are running the game we are
forcing GPU rendering and you know the
game so far hasn't crashed so great you
know it's always nice to see that do the
back eager to do I didn't hit the back
you sir so this face I mean I think okay
you allies in this game this game
actually does support the back key
better yes it does not it doesn't it
doesn't do the weird thing Andrew ergos
and replay stuff and eventually we hit
the back key it's going to say return to
the title screen okay not so bad so so
again it is possible even if you're
doing something that's basically using a
lot of web views um it's really quite
possible to do the back key correctly so
props this developer there's still a lot
of work i think that needs to go through
to make the UI less cluttered looking
and i think that's really what what is
what it you know is one of the things
that's preventing these games from
getting huge huge success everywhere
it's just is just that the whole
interface just feels like if there's
there's so much busy stuff going on but
once again you know it's it's still it's
you look look oh now i leveled up okay
anyway we're like wheel Old up and
severely maybe to add points exactly
same there we go tada so so that's
pretty much this game I don't know
there's not much more to say as far as
the mechanics I didn't get a chance to
play this game as long as some of the
others it does it does have this
summoning concept in it which is which
is pretty cool it's very different so I
have a you could sacrifice some of your
lower ranking creatures to help boost
the level of your of your high ranking
creatures I sort of like that so when
you get a bunch of a bunch of junk that
you don't necessarily want you have
something useful to do with them yes
appreciated that I actually thank you
todd is currently not on the screen
really because our because our engineer
yeah producer is over look I even got
out of the earth oh yeah Daniel this
from me and we heard Todd was talking
here trying to get attention Daniel
sitting there playing there we are all
right hi oh yeah we've got like one and
a half Todd there I really liked the
creature design in this game I thought
they were just sort of different and
imaginative and I was always kind of
looking forward to see what kind of cool
creature I was going to get next in
either through a battle through his
summon my only complaint was the icons a
little boobalicious and I I was sort of
i would be sort of embarrassed to have
this on my home screen if my wife saw
you know and be hard to justify like no
it's actually really good you know
collectible card game well at least you
can at least you can say honey I'm doing
this for work right you know not
everyone else can actually make that
make that assertion so but yeah
definitely definitely something to
consider too so I'm going to actually go
back to the settings menu turn that off
I don't think it's going to affect any
of the rest of our games but as a
general rule I don't want to get out get
here on the Friday review some pain find
out that all of the games are all I'm
not working at all dying because we've
actually turned on GPU rendering most of
time it's not going to cause problems
most time it actually works really
really well but every once in a while
you'll run into something that doesn't
like it so let's just just breathe
now what's next we're gonna get place I
know where our souls we're gonna go two
souls no this is not this is not
technically a collectible card battled
game not but it's really fine it's fun
it's like it's a card game soon puzzle
card game it's a puzzle card game and
actually you know what what I really
love about this game is is just how
beautiful they you know the of a job
they've done with the art were in the
user interface it's it's a gorgeous
gorgeous game wonder why it's showing oh
I do have it showing up in a small part
of the screen there Daniel okay yeah
that's better yeah that's what I wanted
all right okay yeah so uh okay so this
guy just played a bona enhancement cards
and now this card is ridiculously
powerful man I don't have anything that
can even come close so so this is this
is going to be tricky to win yeah so
I've got a couple of interesting options
here I the most i have this kind of
stupid powerful card here this is a risk
to play this because if he's got
something that can take it on either
side yeah I'm not in it it's gonna be
hard to take it back so that's that's
the only that's the only issue there
that we should just give up at this
point yeah you're kind of screwed kind
of screwed cool because they actually
properly use the black back button and
you can now exit yes you're gonna replay
hey that's right so this is pretty cool
this is kind of like I don't know like
there's like are they there's a lot of
card games like this especially people
gambling maybe the final fantasy series
that actually has a similar card game
like this but the point of the
audience's game is that each card has a
basically a number and that corresponds
to the strength so all it really is is
making sure that that number is higher
than your opponent's number when you
want to take that card or as an adult
fence it needs to be the same and it
also has elemental buffs so you can see
the this is this is the green LED don't
really have any but I don't have any
green cards that it can take advantage
of that yet in the in the ones that I
can draw from here and so I've drawn and
it is a card game I'm drawing the top
five cards and we can go and move these
over this is actually a fairly high
level so the chances of this card not
being taken are really low oh because
sure I hate them but you know but I can
take it back with this and then you know
we'll see we'll see whether or not the
shadow
or this is souls so seat souls teaches
TCG we're saving stuff shadow era for
they for the end of the show so yeah
screwed again here I have a shot at this
one still on but right on over here you
think uh yeah that's not a that's oh no
actually you know what I want to do I
want to take two cards at once here you
want to take two cars oh yeah it's my
only my this so the good news is this
will actually lock up one of these two
cards right which is good that one's
that one that one in the corner there is
mine forever and actually because they
think you're gonna win yeah because they
played that it's going to be tricky now
they've locked up they've made it so
that card is pretty much in vulnerable
now to their own attack but I don't have
any you probably need to play this input
in the corner right because you want to
yeah the problem right now is I don't
have anything I can't take that that
card that they just played so this is
this is this as a put something here
yeah I mean for right now this is
probably the best thing this allows me
to protect the card above it so now I've
now I've locked up that card and I've
made that one hard to take right and now
you're gonna win but there's you know
it's not it's not it's not a
particularly decisive victory in terms
of in terms of but at least you know
that's what it is you card but I get a
new card then I can actually go and play
with my deck and I can say all right
well now I've got this great car that
has a nine on it nines are really
important at this point in the game I
can take this one swap that out and then
move here and swap this one back in so
again it's a really fun game and there's
different challenges so you can go to
different areas firewater nature you
notice most of carts you wan we're
basically shadow element based so if you
want water in nature then you go and
play those levels as well exactly and
that and again that's part of the reason
it's getting really hard is that I've
only been playing a shadow so I kind of
wish you didn't have that back button on
screen I mean if they caused me maybe no
yeah there's no reason to actually have
the back button on screen now the good
news is that they is that it actually
works anyway but in this particular case
it's just adding extra stuff you know it
does the away from a UI perspective it's
nice to not have like the deck button
full screen but i think i could do
something else there so that would be
our preference but you know there's lots
of places in which in which you know it
does really make a lot of sense what
they're doing here so also overall good
job not collectible card game but I
it was really cool it was a cool card
game so absolutely absolutely so you can
see kind of what we're doing here the
same thing survival all right so last
but not least we're going to be talking
about shadow era all right so let's
bring it to auto air up here shadow era
has the distinction of being the only of
our card games how very nice actually
yeah besides souls but at least out of
the collectible card games mm-hmm that
actually runs in landscape mode which is
kind of cool it is it is kind of strange
that's not fully touch enabled so you'll
see here that I can't actually drag
around the screen I actually have to
drag that the scroll bar yeah so this is
a pretty direct port i think the pc
version of the game and it kind of it
suffer from that um however that does
not mean that it's not totally beautiful
and when it cools check out hi Perez
mm-hmm beautiful fonts and what's cool
this is actually the AI playings you can
play against other players you can also
play against the AI and and what's cool
about that is you can actually play
against the AI completely offline this
game can be played on an airplane it's
unlike all the other games which are
tied into its cool as angle when I touch
a card you see basically a bigger
version that and check out the beautiful
art some the effects to show that you're
in sacrifice mode so we go to sacrifice
a car so yeah so we so we we have to
squeak we ate we should sacrifice card
here because what the reason why is we
want to get some resources so we
sacrifice that that gets us resources
and that's all we can do a person so you
need resources in order to play like an
attacking card or an ally card or cast a
spell per se which is actually a very
interesting mechanic neelam kind of
brings in a lot of like kind of like the
resource card games that you see let's
say like so he's just as I said as a
sample exactly so they've just put out a
fire snake and that fire snake is going
to attack you're my hero yeah right now
I'll sacrifice you don't have enough
resources even playing your cards right
now exactly so we'll
look at look at some of the things again
you can see the artwork is just
absolutely gorgeous and this game has
actually been turned into an actual card
game right in addition you can go you
can go here that's actually a really
good card I probably should not have
sacrificed that when the wrong thing the
sacrifice yeah that's a feeling Carter
the good news is that I can actually
play I can actually play a card now and
again the only one can play a2 card
because everything takes for ya le card
can play yeah you target opposing ally
is disabled that's good because they
have they have an ally so we'll cast
this will cast it on this guy and now it
can't do anything for two turns you see
what what's what's kind of what's really
cool about this game is in addition to
all of these card mechanics they've
actually got special effects that are
associated with various cards and so I
don't want to start hopefully we can
start playing the fireball but I know I
know that's always a good one to have
though but we went we probably want to
play that one I actually I think we need
an ally though we do need an ally I
think our fireball needs to go oh you
can see actually no well now it's let's
say especially I take special delivery
actually I don't think anyway so it's
pretty cool I mean like you basically
they have all these cool transition
effects i mean like so you know we can
now we can actually catch a far less
horrible yeah and then we'll cast that
will pass it on the hero target that guy
I mean look check it out fireball oh
yeah so it's it's definitely it's
definitely really cool it had done and
also which my favorite one probably is
rain or it actually makes a little
droplets of rain appear all over the
screen just lots of little things that
immerse you in the game there's also
really epic music going on here we can
see we don't have to sacrifice now I
think I think we're okay let's not
sacrifice it skip that at that and let's
go we host uh we can actually look I
don't know I don't really think that
let's do friendly out no
can't play any of these this has only
helps if we actually have that wise I
know I know well no we can do this here
do that yeah might as well haha you're
gonna be totally useless break in and
say this is the dorkiest episode we've
ever it's collectible card game what do
you expect I'm wearing when i was at
past you have any collectible card game
like tournaments and I saw like why like
even in the bar people like oh you think
that magic the gathering cards better
look what I have also Co I like a so
glad you're on board yeah exactly
alright i was just playing cards against
humanity my entire time when aspects but
that's yeah that's definitely correct
that that lots of wrongness but alright
so we now we now actually managed to get
an ally and that's all we can do this
turn because we raised all of our
resources it's actually a real challenge
in the game is figuring out exactly when
it makes sense to use something what it
makes sense a lot of strategy involved
right i mean it's like it's that I mean
this is not for the faint of heart
really it's not a very easy game there's
a lot of elements where you have to kind
of think about how you're going to
sacrifice to get your resources or
whether you want to take an action or a
turn I mean basically the game itself is
over when your own hero is dead so you
want to try to get as many allies are
that as possible so kind of depressing
to have my Ally killed in the very first
round uh but you know but you have
another don't want a separate I don't
want to know and I was I don't I don't
need to sacrifice anything I've got
plenty of resources so I will cast my
Allah here putting out in the turn oh my
gosh you could have done no well uh i
was i could have attacked yeah I should
have probably done that clearly yeah I
know overall really cool i mean like the
background I like the background overlay
of the arm it's really cool to have that
so let's talk about the things they
probably should do so a couple so
they've done it they've done very very
little in really making this game
heavily touch-optimized it is really set
up for the most part 4pcs where I think
the game came from so some some things
that they do do so I love the rain is so
awesome right which means I can't do
anything right now because um that's
okay because I'm going to want to skip
this and I'm gonna want actually cast
out this guy and let's
let's actually target family on there
just reversed armor sure let's milas
might as well matched well attach it to
this this one here and because that's my
hat so many most powerful one and this
guy connect oh don't do it don't I just
killed everyone oh um killed all the
cool effect no yes very cool um anyways
anyway um so that's what you want to not
do after you're all your allies on so
one thing you'll notice is the back
button doesn't do anything in this game
yeah so which does not do it edit and
that's and that's problematic another
thing today fast and I they've done a
little bit in terms of touch so what you
actually do be swiped down it actually
brings down the menu which is cool you
can flick it back up you can also you
can get that same menu by tapping on the
screen but it's kind of cool to have
that available there but there's a lot
of stuff that you really need to do in
terms of in terms of making the game
really Android friendly another thing
that is you're actually playing with
your decks and organizing them you can't
actually sweep across your deck to like
the hover and look at cards okay yeah go
to the deck yeah kind of show you this
interface and also this isn't very
tablet tablet optimized as you can see
it's a really top half it's the top half
of the screen you know it's like there's
all this really really cool stuff that
you could that you can do you're going
to actually want to play with your decks
and you really can't do anything here
really easily it so this to me is where
I want to see them make some changes
especially for tablets but also I want
to be able to take them take my finger
and slide it across yeah I got honey the
top without having a top hat each
individual ones and I mean I have small
hands so it's probably easy for me to
touch and tap the cars that I want but I
don't know for people with large your
hands and it's also i also want to see
for on a tablet i just want to be able
to see a scrolling view like i just want
to see a list view with all of my cards
separated out into blocks and just be
able to scroll through it and you know
and like zoom is the card maybe a meyer
the yard and all that stuff
mean like that's what the club phone
card games are about I mean it's all
that art and that you want to see and
like for all your characters I mean at
your leg your players like just kind of
browse through card after card after
card rightly so also you know you can
see like this the options clear saver
load you know not exactly not not
exactly obvious i hit clear I don't
think I wanted to do that you just clear
your entire day I think so too all right
let's I see that's for clearing that's
we're taking indeed building a deck will
just save this back off so the fact that
you know what I was actually doing there
what you know it was not clear you can
there is a merchant this is actually
really nicely done to you can see you
can actually gives you a nice to you go
and buy card decks exactly and these are
these are not dead by these are not
purchase back but I know can't really go
back yeah it's like wait what do i do to
go back I guess I app on it again but
you know this is again one of those
places in which you know as an Android
user I was totally confused as to how to
navigate through this so but as you can
see there's a lot of stuffs you can do
here you can also buy shadow crystals
which is how you buy these things you
can earn them through offers you know so
there's there's a nice model here but as
I said I think there's just a little bit
of work that needs to go into it to make
it really Android happy so and again
like this is the navigation is this the
thing at the top so it's kind of a
little confusing yeah definitely a
little confusing there is also online
battle you can actually play against
online users and fight them in you know
in battles which is kind of cool even
scroll down the list you get ya es Cobar
again so just so many ways in which you
know this game could be made so much
more awesome but out of all the games
we've looked at you know it's it's the
one that's that it's I think the most
interesting you know honestly in terms
of in terms of its potential great ideas
great art great news of timing it looks
really good on on this tablet and this
guy on my Nexus 7 I mean an even a card
but what what it doesn't have is
actually you know again the the the
crazy amount of of interactivity in
terms of like you know what's great
about Baja mood is it every time you go
into it Mohammed there's a new event
there's something
on and this game to being a because it
is more fixed in its design it really is
about these awesome cards in this great
card game which is very very much like a
like a a card game you playing at a card
table but it does not have all the
additional stuff that rage of bahamut
has and Rex and I think that's you know
I think that's what was one of the main
things that differs these games even
though I love a lot of the presentation
here and i would say i wish this is
where a rage of bahamut needs to go
right like I rage of bahamut looks like
this it's it's basically golden yeah
thanks yeah I mean it's you know it's
just gonna it's gonna do even better
than it's doing now um you know it's
gonna make me want to play it you know
honestly you know this game is the one I
want to play but but at the same time I
recognize that that I want to play
because I love card games and and it's
in and it's gonna drive me back to it
because the game is just so well thought
out right like that you know and not
because there's there's external factors
that are dragging into the game so I'd
like to see these guys do a little bit
more in terms of in terms of making the
game universe dynamic I really and I did
very much want to see the rage of
bahamut guys take a look at this in
terms of the kinds of presentation they
could do and again you know there's lots
of little things here they still need to
do in terms of making the game a better
touch-enabled experience so oh great
start exactly so that's our show you
know again collectible card games it's a
really it's an interesting category
because it monetizes so well and
honestly these games are really fun I
mean even though the overall design is
simple like we're not talking about
heavily dynamic games that have all
sorts of real-time events going on I
mean even shadow where you know has has
has some 3d in it but it's pretty
limited and so you know you know we're
talking about games that ultimately are
about lots and lots of artists and
designers getting together and putting
something together that's compelling
really based upon those factors not
about you neutral peel it's actually
it's very similar in you know in my mind
22 to a lot of the a lot of the gate in
the games at modify as well which is
often games that are just really well
thought out or slots pretty much lots
yeah I'll poker you know it's like um
you know but those are games that are
that are well thought out there they're
designed to be addictive and that's why
that's why they're they're successful
that's a thing right
the joy of trying to find that one rare
card that's going to take you like
that's our or we're getting to that
bonus level and the slot machine machine
or that extra multiplier so anyways
exactly so so next week you know we're
going to the moderator page is going if
it's not up already it'll be up soon to
nominate again whatever whatever games
you're interested in seeing on the show
Co is not going to be here so we're
gonna have another motley crue but
that's okay we should be we should be
hearing from co and her experiences over
at asia in asia and eventually at TGS
which is which is always exciting and so
that'll be fun she's a VR she'll be our
official Asia correspondent here and
other than that on the Friday review I
think we're pretty finished yeah so for
Todd for joining in as a guest guest
host welcome he's probably gonna take my
place next week so goodnight love cats
around shirt yeah yeah thank you you
guys and thanks as always Daniel Pham
for coming in and being our you know
technical director here and we really
missed you in the fume first few minutes
of the show Daniel come on Rachel was
fine I think he didn't even meet you for
the first few seconds well you know that
that can be looked at as an advantage or
a disadvantage depending on how you view
the show alright I'm sure yeah other
stories later right guys oh yeah sure
family right yes yeah okay alright
alright thanks everyone have a good
weekend how many Friday
you